things look to be on the upswing for
Capcom's Resident Evil series we've had
resin the evil 7 which was one of my
favorite games of two years ago and
they're giving fans exactly what they
want now with the Resident Evil 2 remake
we played it learn tomorrow and by Adam
to Resident Evil super fans here and
we're gonna briefly talk about our
impressions of playing Resident you were
to remake recently first off I guess we
should give like a summary for people
who aren't keeping up with it is exactly
what it sounds like it's a remake of
Resident you or two it feels like resin
evil for the controls of resin evil for
mixed with the the pacing and gameplay
of resin evil - it's a sort of sort of
Loki remix of that game Rhodes out going
through that gun shop looks like the
only way I so I just have sort of gone
back to resin or two since we played the
games try and figure out how different
the game feels and it's weird how the
locations feel similar you've got that
familiarity but they've like being
subtly remixed so the locations and
layouts are all slightly different it's
just enough to stoke the nostalgia we
have being too familiar so you go in
there and you have this sense of
familiarity like I know this place but
everything looks a bit different and
because remix it's not like retreading
out footsteps everything feels fresh but
you still have that kind of like I
remember kind of this yeah like it
touches upon like the nostalgia for like
the aesthetics of like the police
station and like Leon's outfit and those
iconic iconic haircuts yeah so it's
saying that although it is a remake they
have taken some liberties with that REME
like kind of like a refreshing where
things are yeah but also there's more
bigger aspects of the game that are kind
of reworked in meaningful ways
definitely yeah but most importantly
though it hasn't lost what makes both
Resident Evil 2 great and also the
Resident Evil franchise for what fans
really love of it
and that's kind of like the
claustrophobia and tension definitely
and that's something that you picked up
we both picked up on but we discussed
this in
in length at length of astraphobia
because it's like this weird how like
the claustrophobia from the original
series like this well in resin evil -
it's very much built around that sort of
limiting limited control scheme where
you're like oh god there's a room full
of five zombies and I can move really
slowly yeah so kind of builds fear
intention that way whereas this
obviously is built around more like the
Risen evil for style of control scheme
with a little bit of sort of subtle
enhancements but they've built that
claustrophobia in different ways we
found like how sort of encounters with
the zombies were very claustrophobic
especially when they got up close to you
like there are a couple instances where
they do have attack you from behind and
the camera just gets super close into
that encounter so like that's the one
thing that in hindsight it kind of
surprises me that it was scary because
you're slow detach from the zombie just
almost like top down at times yeah there
were some perspectives where like you
turn a corner and it'll be behind you
but it was very slow zombies and they
kind of like now though that when they
as they're coming towards you it feels
like the cameras moving as well as a
zombie
so like almost like you're being flanked
by both the camera and the zombie it's
all hearing you into that like really
pulling it's very subtle I'd love to go
back and actually really look at and
examine how they're doing it yeah but
when a zombies coming towards you you
really feel it yeah and you feel that
tension of I need to deal with this
right now dealing with it is easier said
than done
yeah they the somme bees felt a little
bit they were tough weren't they there
we go there are quite a few bullets when
you went for like the head shot they
felt like bullet sponges so the point
where I was like is this right yeah and
then like a certain point I realized oh
they don't want me to kill every zombie
yeah and that's really interesting
because in this game like the way they
maintain like the threat of being in an
area if you don't they all don't want
you to clear an area now and feel like
this is a safe zone now
and that's by making zombies incredibly
hard like it's balancing that kind of
the resource management versus getting
rid of enemies you have to spend a lot
they felt like bullet sponges yeah like
other tactic we use was yes like one
tactic and it's a classic resin evil for
tactic or four five and six exposed
where you peg them in the leg get them
down on the floor and then start
slashing away and you get rid of that
zombie
but I think what they want you to do is
more than more than previous games like
come to terms with the fact that you
can't kill everything nice and a lot of
the times you just need to navigate
around them yeah there was certain
instances instances where like that you
just had to do that yeah where you just
didn't have the ammunition that was
required to take down every zombie and
you just had to navigate around them
like the good thing and I suppose bad
thing about that was that the
environments themselves also feel quite
claustrophobic
in certain areas like where it's like a
tiny tiny corridor you've got one or two
zombies that died in between and it that
felt like classic resident evil actually
because you had that exactly like that
in the first couple of games where
you've got this very tight corridors a
couple of zombies about you have to
either navigate you're like swerving
around them or like you know take one
down and on spot was the slow back away
yeah yeah I think one of the really cool
things that I don't know how much
they've talked about it or like they've
really played it up is like it's got I
don't know if they have a term for it
like dynamic strategic dismemberment
whatever yeah and I never really noticed
that until I use an acid round on an
enemy I actually dissolves limbs because
I used an actually drown in an enemy and
it was like eating away as flesh yeah
and I realized because it reached out
for me and then its arm fell off I
didn't have me I wish I wish we will
kept capturing your game that made me
realize that what you need to do is
incapacitate most of the enemies just
assume you can't kill them but know that
if I can do two shots on the leg that
will take out that one zombies left leg
yeah and it'll have to crawl for me yeah
that means I can get around it and
that's essential because of another
element of the game oh boy perhaps the
most this is good the thing that's gonna
be like the constant threat and like
they're gonna keep resident because are
a big one our big question was how is it
gonna scare people who already know it
yeah and who already know it inside out
enough familiar with it and it is by
using a tyrant
the best way to describe the tyrant is
like the nemesis from three yeah mixed
with the concept from the movie it
follows
yeah he's just always around he can't be
killed no he can be like staggered yeah
you've been like I think you can shoot
him enough to kind of go just like kneel
down on one knee and go be like I was a
bit rough but even then like it's only
through like a fraction of time you
second stay just long enough for you to
exit the room yeah at the room you've
wasted I'm and when you exit the room
it's not like okay he's not coming out
he's coming out yeah he will kick down a
door and follow you everywhere so you've
got to get out of their room and then
run and in when you do run to somewhere
else you can hear him looking for you
yeah though foot the footstep sound
effects were like very I don't know just
fear inducing we have this whole set up
in the police station
an environment that like in knob game
played Emma we hadn't explored at all so
we were kind of thrown into the mix with
this tire and just relentlessly chasing
us and we were like trying to figure out
where to go solve puzzle was where he's
just always there it's not it's like you
know in that sequence early on and risen
number 7 where jack is chasing you and
you can kind of get away from him but
he's still around and he'll follow you
but in a bigger environment with lots
more puzzles and exploration to do so if
Jack like there was a point where he'd
stopped yeah he would ease off and like
in our demo of that section it was like
an hourish yeah an hour-and-a-half fish
maybe and he was always on us like he
was always around there were moments
when we I felt like I got far enough
away from whom they feels like he's not
around yeah but in the back of my mind I
realized that he's actually still coming
towards me and looking for me
yeah and I feel like the AI works in a
way that like say if you're right on the
other side of the map from him you've
kind of lost him on the west wing or
wherever you will and you go over to the
other side I found it a couple of times
where I was sort of doing something
always quiet and then I'd look turn
around and I could see him walking
towards towards you and it's that that
was terrifying
and a couple a couple of exact times
where I got caught with him with a
Zambia and a liquor like in a small room
and you've just like you do not want to
be in that situation it's not like insta
death but you know that all mine this is
a rough situation
what's around you that's why that
knowing that you can't kill everything
it gives you the awareness like I know
there's two zombies in this area so if I
run too if I that's my only option I've
got to be careful about yeah yeah like
speaking of the liquors the liquors are
here in abundance there's a lot of them
about like nine like in the product pass
game I was like oh one job to the roof
won't see that for a little while yeah
you know they are everywhere and they
are aggressive like they working it felt
like they work in packs yeah I felt like
the loss or apt is right yeah so they're
kind of like flanking you and yeah and
like jumping at you to pin you into a
corner and not obviously their iconic
tongues I like slicing at you and I
think the first time I got to the point
where the liquors were scary enough that
I did that classic resin the evil like
panic mover I unloaded a grenade that I
didn't want to do that speaks to a lot
like the fact that it can still scare
people who have loads you like
experience so resin evil seven was a
question of like how are they gonna do
this with an angle and like we were
worried about it it seems like Capcom
are starting to figure out what makes
Resident Evil not strong but remembering
it I know yeah I definitely feels like a
return to that the route obviously
immobilized but I love how I mean
obviously the section of gameplay that
we were playing I feel was quite later
on in the game yes so obviously it
probably not in a normal play three
would introduce zombies then liqueurs
and then obviously the tyrant but we
were playing it with all of them yeah
and it was just what in really tense
yeah we could tell that the pacing was
there like even even though that we had
to like be aware of the fact that we
were being thrown into a slice in the
middle of the game
yeah but you could see the pieces of how
they would pace it properly
yeah and they have things like puzzles
yes
set pieces that kind of ratchet up
detention and lower and that yeah it's
what we worth mentioning the section we
played in the police station was all
with Claire but we also played a chunk
of the game with Leon and ADA yeah which
was great as well and that kind of
introduced some of those sort of the
puzzles and the set pieces that you were
just mentioning we had ADA in specific
in particular I had this very unique to
this game I don't think I've seen this
franchise at all but a new mechanic
where she has like this sort of hacking
gun yeah it's like sort of EMP that's
like a weird like remote hacking thing
for yeah like terminals and stuff like
that yeah controller like doors and
whatnot
it felt quite Detective Mode in Batman
right yeah a little bit yeah very much
like that
yeah yeah and it was just about escaping
an area yeah well like using the
environment and like I found that bit
too to be quite tricky because yeah
again it was it felt like very tight by
at the same time you need to look for
things in the distance that you could
hack yes and it was it wasn't always
clear what the result like of hacking
that was yeah it was a lob like a crappy
together what to do and I in a couple of
those instances you're being hounded by
the tyrant against oh it's sighs about
ratcheting up that tension again we have
to mention the iconic alligator is back
he's there yep I'll show him sadly no we
can't show you it's going to surprise
John it's like I haven't seen it I
wouldn't want to spoil that yeah I was
right it was pretty cool especially for
Resident Evil fans long time but yeah
he's there yeah he's out there and it
was I actually really enjoyed it you
know like when we were playing it I
didn't even know that that was been a
real section of the gameplay we were
gonna be seeing but it was kind of like
oh oh they're doing the other guy this
is the other it was really exciting it's
really good I feel like they've maybe
it's weird to see how it shakes out over
the course of a much longer game with
more more hours but that section it felt
like they struck a pretty good balance
between classic what makes Resident Evil
Resident Evil yeah and the things that
they were trying to do with like four or
five six like the different focus stuff
yeah it feels like they've created
distinct moment
and just figured out how to weave it all
together better yeah so it feels like
again a lot of different varieties and
the flavors of resident evil we have to
be incredibly excited with it definitely
I definitely feel like this is the game
that people the fans of the series are
gonna love right is the gameplay moments
and on the gameplay beats of that
resident evil for experience mixed with
the classic Resident Evil sort of touch
tones of like that 1 2 3 in code
Veronica like that's how it is basically
like we said though it's dis is based on
a very small slice and yes a few hours
and this is our optimism coming through
and we're all fans whether it shakes out
that way we'll have to wait to find out
and of course you can do that by keeping
your eyes locked against Bob of the
website and youtube-dot-com
forward-slash GameSpot where we'll be
covering the game extensively in the
lead up and at launch
we'll have reviews and all that kind of
business we've also got a bunch of
Resident Evil previews already surface a
kind of like stoked your excitement and
you want to hear more about it we've got
a bunch from e3 and Gamescom and and if
you tgs as well you got two games gonna
come and you should look on four slash
GameSpot subscribe while you're there
yeah
in the meantime you can find us on
Twitter I'm at more H and I had a briefs
mace send us your adding all your
favorite Resident Evil moments definite
something like that only some Resident
Evil slash fiction no geo sandwiches
then Leo Joe sandwiches means we'll see
you for the next one
you
[Music]